uh i think we're moving in the right
direction um and that's all we can worry
about
doesn't matter who we play
when they're going to double team teams
will double team james
confidence that there's eventually the
audience
with the shots that he gives that he
spreads around
uh what do you mean well they're
trapping james is there confidence that
they're going to do that
the offense will eventually get going
yeah i mean it's
at that point
four on three he's gotta make the right
place
that beverly is obviously a pretty
well-known pain in the butt
how do you think uh what do you think of
his match-up with james tonight and kind
of the way james dealt with his tactics
44 47 47. oh
pat beth tricky
all that commotion
you think all the getting up inside his
chest
it's good you know play hard playing
hard is a part of the game man i don't
for people like me i play out every
night
as well as he does um
and that's a part of the game he played
hard that's it there's no
nothing else to it you play hard that's
good but
he doesn't make
great decisions sometimes he does a good
job defensively but tonight james took
advantage of him got what he wanted
thank you